mike i'm sitting here i'm thinking hey i
want to in a different industry okay i
want to be the best of the best of the
best like you became a heavyweight
champion youngest ever if i want to be
the best in my sport say this business
what tips would you give me i want to be
i want to be the best in our business
this business this is insurance they're
building their businesses but just the
mindset of wanting to be the best what
is the mindset you can transfer to
somebody being able to just find out the
first guy really really succeeded on
this [ __ ] probably 1900 or something
like that even if he was a crook
let's go from there
and go all the way there and read all
the way till you get to you
okay so one study history yeah study
study until it gets to you
and then you realize those people were
just you and funny clothes
okay so one fantastic i got to go study
history everybody that came before me
what else do i do
then you watch you you you read
everything they did now you practice it
now let's see what this [ __ ] really
works
can you can you teach desire or the
desire has to come from somebody
you can inspire desire
but can you teach it i don't know i
never had to try to teach anybody that
nobody had to teach you the fire because
you had it it was it was within you well
no it wasn't definitely within me you
know somebody had to bring it out and
show that i deserve to have what i could
i have to learn self-love
you know no i don't care how great you
are how much you succeed without
self-love you're nothing
because self-love is discipline
and discipline is doing what you hate to
do but do it like you love it
you know
why didn't it no i agree with you mike i
i i totally agree with you
you've recreated yourself many times
you've reinvented yourself many times
what's the bible yeah i know who you
believe actually you hear it so much you
really believe that i really don't think
you reinvented yourself you don't think
you've reinvented yourself no i think
all the people that wanted me to be down
is dead now
all the people that wanted you to be the
most executive certain people um tax
people this lady kept calling mike you
don't got anything to give us
it's the tackle he wouldn't let me um
wouldn't let me cut my back and then
they died and i think though i didn't
have to pay taxes anymore so they were
just busting my balls
i'm serious because eventually writing
taxes you don't pay a certain amount of
time like 10 years so i don't pay you
don't have no money okay my little cut
just so can you pay it now not yet so
when it's down to like what three
million too many i might be able to pay
you now
you know if anybody had tax problem you
know they take it off you know they take
little off yeah you just got to be
patient oh you know it came from 60 to
93.
you just half the room's not going not
gonna pay taxes for three years they're
gonna be like i'm gonna wait
i was surprised they didn't take my
house or take i was i was waiting for
them to take stuff and they didn't take
any i don't [ __ ]
mike yeah a lot of people have come in
when they see somebody winning you know
charles osnevour i don't know if you
know he's an armenian singer i sound
performed at 19 at 90 years old he said
when i was making money and coming up he
says i was married five times and i saw
a lot of people that acted like they
wanted the best for me but it was very
hard to realize at the end of the day
there was really only five people i can
trust the most because everybody wanted
to kind of take stuff from me how do you
differentiate the difference you know
between flattery and compliment mike
you're so amazing mike's you're this
what's flattery what's a compliment you
have to know who you are first okay
first you know you are
it depends if you want to be flattered
you know it's up to you you know
everybody knows you know you i know who
i am people say the grades all the time
you this you that whatever they say
i know who i am
you know
and i don't i that's who i am
i don't i flatter a lot of people here i
can't say that yeah i do flatter a lot
of people
you flatter a lot of people yeah do you
listen so many great people you have to
sure
sure but flattery you know compliment
flattery and i guess the angle i'm
taking with this is
what what did you look at people to let
them into you meaning you know i like
this guy i trust him i'm gonna let him
in what was your formula to let people
in because the bigger you get you can't
let too many people in right so how do
you process who you let in who do you
keep out right
by knowing who to keep out
i don't know who do you keep out i'm
asking you i i'm a strong believer that
everybody you fight is not your enemy
and everybody helps you is your friend
you know
not everybody you fight is your enemy
and everybody that helps you is your
friend friend not everybody who helps
you is your friend yes
mike your wisdom is on a different level
no because you you know you you put it
out there you're with them that i love
you you gave me the ant the question
the questions the the depth that's the
question yeah
the answer just goes with the question
doesn't hold any more weight it just
goes with the deafness of the question
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]